sí
cuando era niña me gustaba hacer muchas
cosas quería aprovechar cada oportunidad
que se me presentaba ya jugar futbol
volibol básquetbol quería practicar
taekwondo natación quiere aprender a
dibujar ya tocar un instrumento
me gustaba aprender cosas nuevas y
estaba llena de sueños y probablemente
la mayoría de ustedes también los tenía
algunos crían cios pero héroes viajar al
espacio descubrir lugares nuevos e
incluso algunos ya tenían bien claro lo
que querían ser cuando crecieran
algunos querían ser doctores maestros
abogados otros querían ser bomberos
policías artistas e incluso atletas la
pregunta aquí es lo lograron
lograron aquello que soñaba cuando eran
niños o algo que se propusieron
actualmente de todas las personas que
tienen una meta o un propósito solamente
el 70% logra cumplirlos y esto es por
algo que todos tenemos en común el miedo
el miedo cumple un propósito que es
ayudarnos a evitar los peligros ya no
ser dañados por ellos
por ejemplo imagínate que estás en la
cima de un edificio muy alto y te
comienzas a acercar a la orilla y se te
empieza a acelerar el corazón te
empiezan a sudar y a temblar las manos
estas son las sensaciones que produce el
miedo advirtiendo te que hay un peligro
cerca ahora qué pasa si te sigues
acercando cada vez más a la orilla de
ese edificio va a llegar un punto en el
que te caerás te vas a lastimar te vas a
romper un hueso o bueno este es el daño
físico del cual te está advirtiendo ese
miedo por otro lado también tenemos los
llamados miedos irracionales que pueden
producir las mismas sensaciones que los
anteriores tal vez en menor intensidad
pero que no hay un daño del otro lado
del peligro
ahora imagina que estás en la escuela en
un salón de clases y el maestro hace una
pregunta a la que tú sabes la respuesta
pero no levanta la mano porque no te
gusta participar porque no estás
completamente seguro de que la respuesta
sea la correcta porque no quieres que
los demás se rían de ti o con la razón
que sea incluso tratar de voltear como
hacia otro lado tratar de que el
profesor no te vea pero a pesar de todos
los esfuerzos y de todos sus compañeros
te eligen a ti para contestar esa
pregunta y al final si lo hayas hecho
bien o mal no importa porque no te pasa
nada no te rompiste nada no te lastimas
tiene se te cayó nada tú estás bien
el miedo se puede definir como la
angustia a un riesgo oa un daño real o
imaginario también como la angustia a
que suceda lo contrario a lo que se
desea y puede venir de muchas maneras
algunos le tienen miedo a las alturas a
la oscuridad otros a las arañas a las
abejas incluso algo sobrenatural como
los fantasmas pero también puede ser el
miedo al fracaso al qué dirán a lo
desconocido y estos son los miedos que
nos impiden hacer grandes cosas que nos
impiden lograr aquello que deseamos y
que nos privan de nuestras pasiones
todos tenemos miedo y eso está bien no
somos seres perfectos pero lo que no
está bien es que dejes que ese miedo sea
puede de ti y te impida hacer las cosas
que disfrutas que te impida convertir a
la persona que realmente eres o que
quieres llegar a ser
yo quiero compartir mi experiencia con
el miedo y también darte algunos
consejos que a mí me ayudaron a
superarlo
hace dos años yo decidí abandonar la
ecuación el taekwondo el taekwondo es un
deporte que me encanta me ha dado muchas
cosas muchas oportunidades amigos que se
convirtió en familia viajes grandes
experiencias entre otras cosas pero
también le trajo miedos y uno de ellos
fue mi edad que me lastimara el
taekwondo es un deporte de contacto
donde es muy obvio que puede salir
lastimado y una vez en una pelea con una
chica me pegó en la rodilla y me lastimó
tanto ha cargado que no puede caminar
por varios días y que incluso pensé que
ya no iba a poder regresar entrenar pero
logré recuperarlo sin embargo me quedé
ese miedo de que volviera a lastimar y
cada que ha peleado con ella perdía pero
era porque entraba con miedo a la pelea
me derrota va incluso antes de iniciar
ese combate porque que tal y esta vez me
lastimaba y ya no podría volver a
entrenar nunca me daba miedo perder mi
pasión que era algo que me hacía feliz
que todavía me hace feliz y que me hace
sentir todos hacemos todas esas
emociones que te hacen sentir vivo
el otro miedo era dando lograr nada de
no lograr lo que quería y decepcionar a
la gente que creía en mí y de que los
demás se burlaban por no lograr nada
después el tiempo pasó y me di cuenta de
que no tenía caso seguir huyendo de mis
miedos que no tenía caso seguirle
teniendo miedo a salir lastimada porque
era algo que no iba a poder evitar las
lesiones iban a estar presentes tanto en
entrenamientos como competencias y el
respecto a lo demás pues no era pasar mi
vida complaciendo a los demás y siempre
va a haber alguien que nos va a criticar
por las cosas que hacemos y por las que
no
y una vez escucho una frase que decía no
puedes seguir yendo tus miedos va a
llegar un punto en la vida que vas a
tener que encontrar el coraje para
enfrentarlos y superarlos y tiene mucha
razón no podemos ir por la vida dejando
de lado aquello que disfrutamos por algo
que ni siquiera es real mi consejo para
ustedes son algunas de las cosas que yo
han sido importantes para enfrentarse a
lo que venga si decides empezar a
perseguir tus sueños la número uno
que no te importe lo que los demás vayan
a decir oa pensar de ti la gente es
libre expresarse como quiera no y como
dije antes siempre va a haber alguien
que hablar
pero lo importante es tomar esas
críticas que donase a crecer y dejar de
lado las que no porque éstas no te
definen si tú tienes bien claro quién
eres y adónde quiere llegar
la 'número dos' no va a ser fácil tienes
que tener bien en claro que lograr cosas
increíbles no es fácil vas a tener que
hacer muchos sacrificios esforzarte un
montón pero créeme que al final todo eso
va a valer la pena y sé que no es fácil
pero de esta manera velo como un túnel
no siempre vas a poder ver la luz al
final de pero sigues avanzando vas a
llegar a un lugar mejor
el número 3
no le tengas miedo a lo desconocido en
algún punto en el camino para lograr
nuestros sueños vamos a tener que hacer
cosas que antes no habíamos hecho y ahí
es cuando entra el miedo de que a lo
mejor no podamos de que no funcione o de
que no seamos capaces de seguir haciendo
más cosas como esa y es ahí cuando
decimos rendirnos y tirar la toalla pero
hay que hacerlo hay que lanzarnos hay
que arriesgarnos a hacer esas cosas
porque si no no vamos a hacer no vamos a
saber de lo que realmente somos capaces
y obviamente no vamos a ver si logramos
nuestros objetivos y el número cuatro y
la que yo considero la más importante
no le tengas miedo al fracaso
a nadie nos gusta fracasar eso lo sé es
frustrante y en algunos momentos puede
ser desmotivante pero del fracaso se
aprende se ven los errores que se
cometen y se corrigen para que la
siguiente vez salga mejor recuerda que
aquel que intenta y fracasa y vuelve a
intentar está más cerca de lograrlo que
aquel que nunca se atreve a intentarlo
un amigo me dijo una vez que el mid era
como el fuego si logras controlarlo te
va a dar calor pero si no te va a quemar
yo logre controlar y enfrentar mis
miedos
me di cuenta de lo que realmente soy
capaz aprendí muchas cosas y obviamente
logré algunos de mis objetivos y tú
también puedes hacerlo así que ahora te
toca a ti tú qué estás haciendo para
lograr aquello que más deseas